foreign
YouTube channel in today's video we are
going to talk about YouTube SEO we'll be
covering what it is what you need to
know how you can optimize your videos to
get found on YouTube and how you can use
it to maximize your views but before we
go into this let me introduce myself I
am Mark campman I am your digital
navigator for this video and as usual if
you liked the video click the like
button and if you want to join our
YouTube channel click the Subscribe
button below so you become part of our
wonderful Youtube Learning Community on
on simply learned YouTube channel so are
you ready to start let's get into some
numbers here yeah let's give you some
interesting stats about YouTube Before
We Begin and I'm gonna show you that
YouTube has to be part of your digital
marketing strategy Did You Know YouTube
is the second biggest search engine only
after Google there are 98 different
language versions on YouTube making it a
global social network now it would take
a lifetime to watch all the YouTube
content that's uploaded in the last hour
only so it's amazing amount of content
that is being uploaded we as the world's
population we watch about five billion
videos every day on YouTube
did you also know that YouTube
advertising is very important to YouTube
and to Google yeah they generate more
than 30 billion dollar per year in
advertising revenue and on top of that
YouTube has around 2.5 billion monthly
active users making it the second
biggest social media Network in the
world so do I need to convince you any
further that YouTube has to be part of
your digital marketing strategy
so let's talk about what you can do to
increase your chances that your videos
are going to feature in the YouTube
search results and in the
recommendations by YouTube
let's check about what we're going to
talk about in this video we will be
giving you an overview of what is
YouTube SEO
yeah how do you optimize your videos for
YouTube
um how does YouTube search work and how
does your YouTube search engine
optimization work I'm going to share
with you about 10 tips for optimizing
your video for search on YouTube and
then at the end I'm going to share with
you my favorite YouTube SEO tools I will
also show you in a demo where to find
all the tools that you can use within
YouTube and within some of those tools
to optimize your videos for SEO
so let's start with explaining what is
YouTube SEO as mentioned earlier YouTube
is the second most popular search engine
right after Google in fact YouTube
searches are actually more in numbers
than Microsoft Bing AOL and ask.com
combined so we're talking about a very
important part of your search strategy
YouTube as I mentioned earlier has about
2.6 billion active monthly users as of
2022 making it the second biggest social
media Network
only
um proceeded by by Facebook yeah so now
62 percent of global consumers say they
use YouTube and since the creation of
YouTube its Mission has been to provide
fast and easy video access to users and
the ability to share videos frequently
and since then it has grown Beyond
expectations now with so many people
uploading videos on the one hand and
watching videos on the other hand how
you do you make sure that your video
features in the top of the YouTube
search results
and that's where YouTube SEO plays a
vital role
so before I explain YouTube seo let me
give you a little bit of a history about
YouTube late 2004 an idea for a website
for users to upload video dating
profiles was born and in February 2005
the website launched to a small subset
of users as I said earlier I say video
dating platform now based on feedback
from their subscribers in April 25 or
April 2005 YouTube turned into a free
video hosting platform where each clip
had a unique Link in April 2005 the
first video ever was uploaded on the
website by one of the the YouTube
Founders and in May 2005 YouTube
launches its better version to the
public for the first time and it became
a massive hit in a year later October
2000 0006 Google acquired YouTube for
the not too small amount of 1.6 billion
US dollars
in 2007 YouTube allowed YouTube creators
people who upload videos to earn money
from their content based on ad Revenue
yeah turning their hobby into a career
and that of course gave a tremendous
push of people getting into YouTube
creating content for YouTube where they
could link it to advertising where they
could make a substantial income now in
no November 2008 YouTube expands it ad
offering to sponsored videos and free
pre-roll ads and in 2009 they launched a
new music video service called fivo in
collaboration with vivendi so it moved
on in 2010 one of the most famous
YouTubers Felix kelberg joins YouTube to
create content under the Channel's name
pewdp and that is now one of the biggest
channels that you can find on YouTube in
April 2011 YouTube entered the broadcast
business launching YouTube live and in
August 2012 2012 it became the go-to
place for presidential elections by
launching the YouTube elections Hub it
grew exponentially and by 2013
YouTube had reached over a billion
monthly users
some other interesting facts in January
2016 the music video for Adele's hello
was the fastest video on YouTube ever to
hit 1 billion views
and a very strategic move for YouTube
was in November 2018 when they rolled
out a stories-like feature YouTube
shorts yep where they would sort of
relate to Snapchat and Instagram stories
where videos are automatically deleted
after a day
in November 2019 YouTube announced that
the service would phase out the classic
version of YouTube Studio yep and to all
YouTube creators by Spring 2020 and I'll
show you later what the latest version
of YouTube studio is all about in July
2021 YouTube did a massive cleanup of
all unlisted videos prior to 2017 were
set to be private making them unplayable
and in 2022 YouTube becomes the second
biggest social media Network after
Facebook so a whirlwind of a development
of a growth of an adoption in the market
it's being played and being used all
over the world and it is the channel of
choice for the younger generation to
watch TV and to watch video so a
spectacular development for a fantastic
channel so what is YouTube SEO now
YouTube SEO is a set of activities that
you need to do to enhance the search
rankings of your YouTube videos and or
your YouTube channel in other in other
words when a user does a query on the
YouTube search bar yeah which is related
to your videos what you do what do you
need to do to make sure that your video
features higher in the YouTube search
rankings or in the recommended videos
based on that search
now many businesses of today they see
the power of search for a YouTube it has
showing up and the importance of showing
up higher in the search results it helps
them to reach more people because more
people will click on the the video links
it helps in building and promoting their
brand it helps them in creating customer
engagements more people will like the
videos more people will engage with the
videos and it is a great opportunity for
Brands to Showcase their expertise so it
is a no-brainer for businesses to be on
YouTube these days and to put all the
effort in place to show up high in the
search rankings
so as you know the engine of a search
engine is what we call the algorithm so
before we dive a bit deeper into YouTube
SEO let's have a look at this YouTube
algorithm YouTube says in their own
documentation that the algorithm is a
feedback loop in real time that
recommends videos to individual viewers
according to their different interests
now quality of the user experience
wasn't
that important at the initial start of
YouTube for the first seven years
YouTube rewarded videos that got the
highest number of clicks or views
yes so all based on number of clicks and
number of views but soon content
creators started to abuse the algorithm
approach and tricked people into getting
more views because of clickbait video
titles or catchy thumbnails so Google
had to do something about this and to
tackle this misuse of clicks and Views
and improve the user experience
today announced an update to the
algorithm in 2012. they prioritized
considering videos that had higher
attention time a higher watch time a
longer watch time
but still YouTube wasn't able to provide
what an individual user was looking for
so in 2016 they announced another update
to their algorithm and that's where they
announced to do to use machine learning
and deep neural networks for its
recommendation system completely
changing the user experience of a
YouTube user in other words YouTube is
focused on hooking users into valuable
addictive content based on their
interests
yes so how does YouTube SEO work
let's dig a bit deeper into the YouTube
algorithm overall the YouTube algorithm
affects the search results and the
recommendation streams so what do I mean
with that
in response to a user's query the
YouTube's algorithm analyzes videos
across thousands and thousands of
channels to return a list of the most
relevant videos
and the YouTube search results are
highly affected by YouTube's algorithm
yeah and the factors that will make your
video pop up in a user search query are
your videos comments the likes the watch
time you can call this engagement your
videos titled the description the
keywords the tags we call this the
metadata that matches the users query
yeah so a lot of reasons yeah why the
YouTube algorithm picks your video to
show up higher in the search results
now the algorithm goes through a
two-fold process for recommending videos
to a user
yeah there is the search results but the
second part of this the SEO is the
recommending video to a user which you
see on the left side after your search
results first it ranks video Based on
data of their performance Analytics
so for instance videos that are trending
they have a higher priority
second it matches videos based on the
user's history and the similar content
they may have watched earlier so
ultimately they would end up spending
more time on the platform going through
as many videos as possible automatically
watching as many ads as possible
so now you got an idea about the end
goal of YouTube's algorithm in 2022 and
how it works to create a better user
experience
right now that you understand the
YouTube algorithm
how can you make this algorithm work
with you what I'm going to do here I'm
going to share 10 tips with you on how
to optimize your videos for search so
let's start with tip number one tip
number one is to make sure that you
conduct your keyword research before you
optimize your videos
make sure your keywords are relevant to
your video
because they allow YouTube to determine
the video topic and index the content
and relate it to the user queries
so here are five simple steps for you to
do to do your video keyword research
first start with topics that you want to
be an authority for
identify those topics and then for each
of these topics you generate keyword
ideas you find those keyword ideas by
going on YouTube for the YouTube
suggests and you can go to Google as
well you go to other video platforms you
go to keyword recommendation tools
yes so you generate keyword ideas then
for those keyword ideas you're going to
look for monthly search volumes and the
difficulty for those keywords how
difficult is it to get a higher search
ranking for those keywords and there are
tools that you can use to find out about
these keyword metrics
you're then going to conduct a YouTube
serp analysis so you're going to analyze
the search engine result page for your
keywords and find out what you can see
yeah it's a serp analysis is very
important because it helps you to
determine the types of keywords that are
currently ranking for that keywords or
the type of videos that are currently
ranking for that video
it helps you in determining the quality
of those videos and it also helps you in
determining the search intent for those
keywords why are people searching for
those words is it with a buying intent
is it with a learning intent or is it
with an informational intent
and the fifth tip on your keyword
research is to select those Target
keywords that are the most that have the
I search volume of the the the the the
best competitive difficulty yeah so it's
finding the right balance and come up
with a list of keywords that you can
start using for your videos
and then you're going to assign those
keywords to your video
yeah and make sure that those keywords
are relevant to the content
and that you use them in the title that
you use them in the thumbnail that you
used them in the the the
transcription of the video and I'll tell
you more a bit about that in a little
bit yes so it is all about capturing the
content of the video make it unique and
encouraging viewers to watch your
content so keyword research is a very
important topic
second is to make sure that you use the
right title for your videos
titles is critical there are two
elements of your video that will decide
whether people watch a video or not it
is the title of the video and it is the
thumbnail of the video and more about
the thumbnail later so get a good catchy
title
make sure your keywords are in your
title as well yes so it's not only about
explaining the content of the video in a
very strong title but also
encouraging people to click on the video
link
yeah so your keywords and your title
play a very important role in this
right let's look at the third tip that
is the description of your video
yeah and for the algorithm the
description is very important the
algorithm uses the description to check
the topic of the video so make sure that
your description includes the keywords
as well
so the video description is the text
below each of your videos and viewers
can read the YouTube video description
by clicking on the see more button below
the video
yeah so these descriptions usually
include a short explanation of what the
video is about including the relevant
keywords links to any resources
mentioned in the video maybe affiliate
links website links maybe social media
handles
definitely asked if you were to
subscribe and chapters and timestamps
and Google now has the feature to sort
of split up the content of your video in
timestamps and people can jump from
timestamp to time stamp
so YouTube descriptions including all
the right elements like the informative
text the links the buttons they can help
the viewer to discover your video can
help you to increase your subscribers to
increase your views and to increase your
watch time
so tip four is about tags
very important to add tags to your video
YouTube uses tags to effectively index
and search for videos but also to
suggest other videos you might be
interested in
they help again the YouTube algorithm to
understand what your content is all
about and to serve it to the right users
so here are some best practice tips on
using tags don't overdo them don't use
too many tags
use trending text yeah so find trending
topics with YouTube Auto suggests
yeah so and use those trending text be
specific with your tags for example a
road trip is a tag that is less Broad
and has a higher chance of ranking well
in search engine than for instance the
word vacation because that is too
generic
also includes synonyms think about the
words your audience is likely to use
when describing the topic of your video
and use those synonyms to broaden the
reach of your tags and if you're you out
of ideas use a tag generator to identify
related and potentially trending tags a
really good tool for this is tune pocket
right let's move on let's go to the next
tip tip number five YouTube creates
transcriptions and captions for your
videos
and you can create your own
transcription
because the algorithm can't interpret
visual content only text and code so if
you can transform your video in text
through a transcription that can really
help in your search Effectiveness so a
transcription is the translation of what
is spoken in the video
and you can use this transcription for
subtitles in your video as well
they will also help you to generate
captions for your timestamps in your
video now very important YouTube will
automatically generate a transcription
file
but be aware this transcription file
will not be indexed for search the
because the raw file may have typos or
wrong translations wrong interpretations
from the Google automatic transcriber
so what you need to do is that you edit
the transcription file and take out a
typo and the mistakes and once you've
done that you've then uploaded that
transcription file up to your video and
once you've uploaded It Again YouTube
will then index the file and use it for
the search
so very important and I'll show you
later where you can find the
transcription file
tip number six think about the length of
your videos
focus on both the watch time and the
video length
and let's be realistic about it if it
takes 20 minutes to explain how to do
something yeah on your video then make a
20 minute video if you can say it in one
minute then make a one minute video
Don't Waste people's time by stretching
out the content just to hit a certain
number of minutes it's not about how
long your video is it is about when
people stop watching your video
if you can keep watching if you can keep
people watching longer than average then
you'll get more views and eventually you
will get more subscribers
now YouTube wants to recommend videos
that people stay engaged with or in
other words watch longer so if you can
increase your watch time for your videos
then YouTube will reward you with better
rankings in search results and
recommendations across their site which
ultimately leads to more viewers
so a good way to keep people engaged is
to use screens and YouTube cards
and that is tip six
yeah so an end screen is the YouTube
feature that appears in the last 5 to 20
seconds of your video
and you can use it to promote videos
playlists merchandise and external
websites your end screen can help you to
get more views more traffic and
subscribers from every video
YouTube cards are a bit more flexible
they are interactive cards that you see
throughout a video
that let you share clickable links to
relevant content throughout your video
you can use those cards to promote a
related video or playlists to promote
your YouTube channel to encourage
viewers to take a call or to take a poll
to direct responses to a verified
off-site location like a specific
landing page or to ask viewers to donate
to a charity this will only work for the
US by the way so non-us
viewers cannot do those donations to
charity
right next tip
mixtape is making sure that you increase
audience engagement by increasing the
watch time of your video
yes so this is all about the content of
your video
and be clever with the content in your
video try to use elements of surprise in
your video or changing the pace of the
music or ask for audio participation for
instance by adding a quiz in your video
very important to maintain people's
interests
yeah and some other tips that you can do
to keep people's interest is to make
sure you have a strong video opening
yeah where you capture people's initial
interest to make sure that you use
chapters in your videos yeah because
that will give people a guideline of
what to look out for use pattern
interrupts as we call them like music
paste different Graphics different
camera angles are you storytelling
techniques why are people so interested
in stories because stories use
techniques like good and bad yeah or one
extreme to The Other Extreme yeah to
actually keep people engaged in the um
in the story maybe create longer videos
for a more targeted audience where you
know they have a better interest in
watching your videos maybe look at
developing a series of videos
yeah because then you build up loyalty
and you build up kind of a viewer
membership for your video series and
then obviously use the YouTube insights
YouTube analytics to learn about how
effective your um your interrupts in
your video are
final there then there is tip number
eight
tip number eight is an obvious one make
sure that in every video you upload on
YouTube that you promote your channel
and promote the likes the people to like
your video yeah at the beginning and at
the end of your video just like I did on
this video and I'm doing it now if you
like this video click the like button if
you want to subscribe to our video click
the Subscribe button or subscribe to our
Channel you have very important that you
do that
now a tip that is often overlooked is
the power of the thumbnail
yet people make a decision as I
mentioned earlier to watch your video
based on the title of your video and the
thumbnail and the more exciting your
thumbnail the more likely people will
click
yes so now YouTube will create
thumbnails for you but if you don't like
them you can also upload your own
uh your own thumbnails so you can design
those on any tool um any creative tool
make sure that if you upload your own
videos that they accurately represent
your videos
include a shortened version of the title
of your video
yeah make sure that the text is large
enough to read Because particularly on
mobile and remember about 60 percent of
people watch YouTubes on their mobile
yes so make sure that the text is large
enough to read use contrasting colors to
capture the attention make sure that you
pay attention to White space between the
images and create add your brand logo to
your thumbnail as well and the final tip
it goes out it goes without saying tip
number 10 make sure your video keeps
your viewers attention
yeah your videos have to be unique they
have to be different they have to be
engaging
the best videos are controversial
educational funny or shocking
check your analytics your YouTube
analytics to see and to analyze your
viewing behaviors learn from that and
tailor your content to what you learn in
your Analytics
okay so those are the 10 YouTube SEO
tips and now let me show you where to
find all this in YouTube
so if you go to YouTube
yeah I'll show you here this is of a
company
um and this is their YouTube kind of
Channel yeah if I go to the channel of
the company then here you see the
channel it is a shoe store and here you
see their videos now I'm not going to
explain the channels to you but here you
see if you go at the top right
you see this little photo here you're
going to click I'm going to switch the
account I'm going to my
solution and I'm gonna here have the
dashboard I'm going to look at the
content this one
how we made two and a half thousand
African kids happy with a pair of shoes
so here you see the metadata of this
video
okay so let me show share with you the
elements that we discussed first of all
there is your video title
that you can add here
right how we made two and a half
thousand everything gets happy with a
pair of shoes then here you have your
description
remember keywords actually what I did
here I took the script off the video and
put it here in the description yeah you
have a lot of characters available here
I always start a description with the HD
with the website
because that is another free opportunity
to get a link to your website
yes so there is your title your
description then if I scroll down
then here you see your thumbnail
I've picked a thumbnail yeah the one
that YouTube created for me I can also
upload my own thumbnail
okay I'm not going to go into the
details I'm just focusing on the
elements that we discussed so here you
see show more and this is where I can go
2D automatic chapters
yeah so those are the chapters that
YouTube will create for you and here you
see the tags
so this is where you can add all the
tags for your video
okay
and then you have the language recording
date
Etc
and then finally here you have the
visibility here you have the section for
subtitles or transcriptions and your end
screen and your cards remember what we
talked about
so let's look at these subtitles
here you see the file
that YouTube created and that we have
updated as it were took out the pilots
YouTube does this automatic you can
download it and then you can edit it
so very useful very powerful tool and
this is by the way if you need to
transcribe any text for any particular
reason yeah just upload a text as a
video on YouTube and YouTube will
transcribe it for you
yep and then when you play the video
there you see here how the text
this is how she belongs to 40 of the
African population yes so extremely
powerful feature of YouTube the the
transcriptions so close that and then
here you see your end screen that you
can pick so you could a video and a
subscribe you can put it at the bottom
you can put it at the top you can put it
in the middle or you can relate to two
videos and here you see the end of the
video where you can place those uh end
screens
okay and the same with the cards
so here you see the type of car to you
want a video card and then you can say
which video do you want to relate it to
do you want a playlist do you want to
promote another Channel
or do you want to add a link but you
need to be part of the YouTube Partner
program in order to add links to your
cards
right
so that is all there is to uploading
your metadata to your videos a very
important part
to your YouTube SEO
oh let's go on and let's look close
today's session
yeah with sharing my favorite YouTube
SEO tools with you there are five tools
here and I want to actually highlight
two of them number one is canva number
two is socialblade
tubebuddy a refs keyword Explorer and
scyphy
so social blade is a good tool to
examine any popular YouTube video
yeah and then a reps keyword Explorer is
a tool where you can study keywords and
not necessarily only for YouTube but
also for your Google SEO
one of my favorite tools on YouTube is a
tool called tube buddy it is
specifically dedicated for SEO with a
lot of helpful functions yes so it
actually helps you with performance
tracking analyzing keywords yeah and it
is a very simple Google Chrome plugin
let's go to tube
buddy
Chrome extension
yeah here is Chrome tubebuddy
yeah so here you see the tubebuddy
extension and here I click add to Chrome
ADD extension
and you will now see appear that we're
going to add an extension
yeah it has been added to Chrome and now
you see here the um the extension okay
okay so if I now go to a video let's say
simply learn
social media
yep and I pick a video social media
marketing course you can now see that we
installed tubebuddy as a plugin and we
create an account and we logged in and
look at what I see now of the video that
I have on my YouTube screen yeah I have
what we call videolytics
I can see the number of views for the
video the number of comments number of
likes yeah I can see their social
channels I can see their channels uh the
Youtube channels I can see the best
practices does it have a high res
thumbnail have info cards been added and
Screen being added has comments been
pinned Etc so some work to do here and
here I get the tags that are being used
for this video I can also show search
rankings yep and I can have additional
tools as well where I can look at
various elements like search ranking
share tracker Etc so a very powerful
tool on YouTube through tubebuddy that
gives you a whole load of
metadata of each video so if you are
doing a social media video and you want
to upload it on YouTube look on
um videos that are similar to the one
that you want to upload and look at
their tags look at their best practices
learn from that and you can use that for
your own video
okay so that is tubebuddy and then the
next tool I want to share with you is a
simple editing Graphics editing tool it
is a tool called canva
is what I call photoshop on steroids it
is a very easy site to create Graphics
to create thumbnails to create Graphics
that you can use on your videos and
there's even video Tools in here as well
that you can use yeah you can create a
design you can just say let's see what
you can create specifically for YouTube
you can do a YouTube Banner a YouTube
channel logo YouTube display ad a
profile picture you can make YouTube
Shorts YouTube thumbnails YouTube video
chapters so lots of stuff that you can
create for YouTube where it has a set of
templates for you that you can use in
your in your design for your YouTube
video or your YouTube channel
so very powerful tool
I love can Farm yes Sophie is a good
tool for
um for analytics so you can bring your
YouTube analytics into sci-fi create a
dashboard and it allows you to monitor
success of your videos and your top
ranking keywords so lots of great tools
that you can use for optimizing your
videos and my favorite are tubebuddy
canva and SciFi so that is all there is
to YouTube SEO I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked the video feel free
to click the like button of course and
if you want to join our Channel click
the Subscribe button by clicking below
and that's a wrap I see you in our next
video and for now I wish you a wonderful
day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here